Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim. Ja, ich habe auch gerade was verbotenes getan.
Was? Wie was verboten ist.
Gutes im verborgenen.
Logbuchen, Netzpolitik,
Zweihundertsechzehn Folgen werden es gewesen sein, wenn diese dann endlich zu Ende geführt ist. Jetzt fangen wir aber erstmal damit an
und ja die
Aufregung steigt die Hacker haben neue Einnahmequellen vor sich da die Dollarzeichen gehen durch die Szene.
Verpflichten Sie sich jetzt.
Nach einer kurzen allgemeinen Grundausbildung kommen sie in den Genuss von Cyber.
Genau. Oh Weiher.
Heute wurde die die Bundestagwehr gegründet, also nicht die nicht die Freiwilligenarmee, sondern die,
oder der ist ja auch freiwillig, aber mit Soldaten also Ursula von der Leyen war dann,
feierlich heute oder wird heute dann mit äh mit Generalleutland Ludwig Leinhos,
irgendwie ihn mit einem Appell zum zum zum Chef der Cyberkrieger oder sowas benennen und der wird der erste Cyber-Inspekteur des,
Kardozier werden sie es wahrscheinlich nennen. Das Kommandos, Cyber und Informationsraum.
Wow, was für ein Name.
Ja und da wird äh der hat zunächst dann zweihundertsechzig ITler,
und äh dann am ersten Juli kriegt er vier weitere Bundeswehreinheiten, die dazu kommen, nämlich das oder äh ich weiß, nee, die sind dann da, aber die muss ja jetzt irgendwie auffüllen, das Kommando strategische Aufklärung.
Das Führungsunterstützungskommando, das Zentrum operative Kommunikation und das Zentrum für Geoinformationswesen. Also strategische Aufklärung ist glaube ich klar, dass es dann eben,
Spionage und Hacking würde ich schätzen, ne? Führungsunterstützungskommando weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Operative Kommunikation klingt auch nach nichts Gutem.
Für Führungsunterstützungsgeband können sich um Admins handeln.
Stimmt, dass du die annimmst, genau. Dann das Zentrum operative Kommunikation, das klingt so ein bisschen nach wahrscheinlich äh sichere Kommunikation irgendwie unterhalten, Verschlüsselung oder sowas. Und das Zentrum für Geoinformationswesen.
Die klickt dann in Google Maps rum.
Sollen wir das nochmal nachgucken? Also ist eigentlich auch egal. Insgesamt wollen sie dreizehntausendfünfhundert Posten haben. Das ist stark, weil das sind mehr Besucher, als wir beim CC-Kongress haben.
Ja, wie wollen sie die denn dann füllen?
Ist schwierig, also,
Was dich dennoch ganz interessant finde, das wird in einem Artikel von äh Detlef Beuchers hatte, den glaube ich geschrieben bei Heise. Ähm so am Rande erwähnt
angegliedert ist ferner das das Forschungszentrum fürs Cybersicherheit der Universität der Bundeswehr in München.
Wo dann auch die zentrale Stelle für Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich zitis äh ist,
Ich wollte mich jetzt erstmal noch darüber aufregen, ob die denn keine äh hier wie heißt das Wehrausschlussklausel haben, aber es ist die Universität der Bundeswehr. Insofern, die werden wahrscheinlich ähm so etwas nicht haben.
Ja.
Heißen die einzelnen Standorte bleiben erhalten, das ist ähm.
Wahrscheinlich ähm.
Haben die schon welche.
Nee, die werden das wahrscheinlich an den existierenden irgendwie machen, oder?
Machen kein neuen Standort, sondern docken das irgendwo ran.
Genau die, das ist ja im Internet, das ist ja völlig egal, in welcher Pampa die dann da rumhängen. Hauptsache, Hauptsache, die haben sich da mit einem Spaten äh durch den Wald eine Faser hingelegt und dann können die Hecken.
Ja, das dachte mir schon, ihr müsst vielleicht nochmal ein paar Dessert-Anschlüsse nach beantragen.
Hi, die sagt, also.
Die sind ja auch teilweise so richtig wirklich in der Pampa. Das könnte ja dann durchaus auch äh die sonstige digitale äh Digitalisierungsstrategie voranbringen. Voranbringen, weil übera.
Voranbringen, ne? Ja oder dass die Leute eine Pampa-Diät, sage ich mal, wenig wenig berufliche oder Bildungsaussichten haben, der sagt, ja, dann gehe ich halt so bunt. Da habe ich das Internet. Das wäre doch, das, vielleicht ist das die.
Vor allem ich meine wenn man sich mal so anschaut wie so 'ne Bundeswehr, also überhaupt so 'ne Armee vorgeht. Die haben ja sowas wie Brückenpanzer und so weiter, weißt du, so schnell Ausbau. Und wenn dir das mal für Glasfaser auch umsetzen
Ja und dann poltert hier vielleicht äh demnächst einfach so einen Trupp äh durch die Straße,
Ja, erstmal hier die äh militärische Infrastruktur bereitstellen muss in Form von Glasfaser.
Für den Apfelbrauch und da hat ein Autobahn jetzt. Für den Cyberkrieg, ja, früher die Autobahn für die Panzer gebaut, jetzt gibt's da hinten eine Autobahn für für den Cyberrohr.
Versorgungslinien heißt das jetzt.
Ja, also.
Ich könnte hier auch mal eine neue Versorgungslinie.
Wir können's, wir können uns da ja deswegen ganz gut drüber lustig machen, weil die einfach keine Leute haben, ne? Also die ähm die suchen also jetzt äh,
wollen auch Zivilisten fürs Affical Hacking haben? Affical Hacking finde ich ganz geil. Also ähm,
Es gibt irgendwie so, also im verwende so IT-Sicherheits äh Spezialist
bis ohne Kunden, da musst du so Zertifikate kriegen, ne? Also irgendwie damit du irgendwie deine äh damit du deine Kompetenz unter Beweis stellst, ne? Also so CI, SSP, Surtified, Information, Security,
hast du nicht gesehen oder CIA, Circi Fight Affical Hacker äh ist dann dann wird halt, ne, da musst du mal so eine die Begriff, so eine Begriffsmalte Petroyce Test in IT Security machen.
Was was bei den Essige Hacker muss man dann irgendwie die Satzung des CC auswillig lernen.
Nee, das ist ah, das hat mit Ethik überhaupt nichts zu tun. Das ist äh das sind halt im Prinzip so ein bisschen Zertifikate. Es gibt ja jetzt nicht irgendwie ein kannst ja nicht sagen, ich habe einen Abschluss in IT-Sicherheit. Also du kannst sagen, du hast Informatik studiert und was weiß ich in Bochum
dich auf IT-Sicherheit spezialisiert oder sowas, aber um eben diesen,
Dieser Lehre, was da die Ausbildung angeht, irgendwie zu begegnen gibt, ist auch da eben Zertifikate. Die äh von unterschiedlichen Wert sind sicherlich bei einer, bei einer Bewerbung äh oder bei einer ersten Bewerbung oder bei einer,
kalt, kalt Wehrbewerbung oder sowas, ist das sicherlich nicht verkehrt. Wenn man da so Zertifikate hat, aber Efficial Hacking ist jetzt nach meiner Kenntnis nichts. Ähm äh wo jetzt also
machen dann hauptsächlich die, die das nicht machen, ne? Äh die sich dann jetzt Kapitän. Ähm aber vielleicht habe ich da auch ein bisschen, ich.
Bedenklich, sehr bedenklich, dass sie dann ausgerechnet sowas so eine neue militärische Struktur mit diesen ganzen Itlas besetzen.
Ja und die wollen eine Cyberreserve gründen. Das auch noch, ne? Also einmal diese ganzen Verpflichtungs äh und das, was du jetzt gerade siehst, ähm.
Diese diese Werbe
Plakate, die überall hängen, ne? Freiheit. Wir verteilen die Freiheit jetzt auch im Netz. Äh wann darf man Hacker haken und solche Geschichten? Haben wir uns ja schon seit längerem drüber lustig gemacht, ne? Und es ist auch lustig, weil
Im Prinzip hättest du dir vor vor zwei Jahren in einer Runde was weiß ich nach dem dritten Joint und den fünften fast
Wein äh irgendwie das nicht ausdenken können, was sie heute tapezieren, da hättest du das wären Treppenwitz gewesen, was die, was die gerade hier an an Plakaten aufh,
ne? Da hättest du in der, in einer lustigen Runde gesessen, hättest du gesagt, nee, komm, das können wir nicht machen, das merken die sofort, das ist doch völlig übertrieben.
Wir haben doch glaube ich sogar mal irgendwie so eine, das war doch sogar ein Sendungstitel, unsere Freiheit wird auch im an der Firewall verteidigt. Das haben die am Ende plakatiert,
Das meinen die, äh das meinen die offenbar ernst? Ähm noch dazu, was auch nicht witzig ist, ist, dass ich meine.
Heute ist im Prinzip offiziell der Tag, wo die Bundesrepublik Deutschland und ihr Militär.
Nicht nur entschieden haben, sondern auch in die Tat umsetzen, dass dieses geniale, weltumspannende Netz,
Was wir irgendwie seit etwas mehr als zwei Jahrzehnten haben, was äh eine ganze Menge Wissen, Freiheit und sonst was in diese Welt gebracht hat und ein paar Probleme,
jetzt zum Kriegsschauplatz wird. Und ich finde, finde eigentlich nichts enttäuschender als das,
Wenn man irgendwann mal sagen würde, so die Geschichte der Menschheit und sagt, guck mal hier, dann haben die äh sind die irgendwann auf die Idee gekommen, haben die gesagt, gibt eins und null, machen wir einen Computer draus. Dann haben die eine rasante Entwicklung hingelegt, dann haben die diesen, diese Computer vernetzt, dann haben die,
Licht durch Kupfer gepresst, um um miteinander zu reden und die haben Ideen des freien Wissens und der freien Software und alles Mögliche geschaffen
Wikipedia, die haben auf einmal das Wissen der Menschheit dokumentiert. Die sind hingegangen, haben sich gegenseitig irgendwie mit Freifunk, das Zugang zum Internet verschafft, die haben auf einmal konnte jeder bloggen und dann ja und dann ist äh Militär reingegangen. Ich bin mal gespannt, also,
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, ob er demnächst Blauhelm-Soldaten kriegen bei Cyberangriff oder so, ne. Aber das ist schon irgendwie eine eine ziemlich historisch gesehen, traurige Geschichte.
Ja, andererseits machen wir uns auch nichts vor. Ich meine, die die Bedeutung des Netzes ist halt jetzt auch da gelandet, wo wir sie auch immer gesehen haben, so
und sie umfasst halt äh
sie definiert jetzt auch den Wirtschaftsfluss, damit das Geld und damit auch die Einflusspferden und es ist ja auch jetzt nicht so, dass es dort keine realen Angriffe gibt,
die Bundeswehr in dieser Form,
Da jetzt äh die richtige Antwort ist, andererseits könnte man ihr vielleicht auch schon fast vorwerfen, wenn sie sich jetzt,
Zumindest nicht Kompetenzen aneignet in diesem Bereich, dann ist sie wahrscheinlich auch äh.
Es ist, ich will da gar nicht sagen, die Bundeswehr hat jetzt die die Welt äh zu einem schlechteren Ort gemacht. Das ist äh im Zweifelsfall leider notwendig,
Ich bin sich als Staat darauf vorzubereiten, dass das eine Rolle spielen wird, deshalb und ähm.
Ich meine nur so historisch. Ja, ja. Hat man sich das anders, also.
Unsere romantische Verklärung.
Romantische Verklärung der wir mehrere Jahrzehnte angehangen haben. Leid ist jetzt nicht gesagt ah geil lass uns Internet machen, da können wir Krieg führen. So das ist halt wirklich so ein Schei,
Menschheit ist äh schwierig.
Ist schwierig. Braucht auf jeden Fall noch eine Weile.
Aber wenn du dir jetzt mal anschaust, was die für Personalbedarf haben, ne? Also,
Nach Angaben der Bundeswehr werden zweitausendsiebzehn, zweitausendachtzehn insgesamt noch eintausend IT-Soldaten und achthundert zivile und militärische IT-Atmens
gesucht. Mit er bereits erfolgter höherer Ausbildung. Ich frage mich, wie die, was die für eine Vorstellung haben. Ich glaube nicht, dass dass es die gibt
Also wenn ich mir anschaue, wie verzweifelt ungefähr jedes Unternehmen, was irgendwas mit IT zu tun hat,
gerade ähm Fachkräfte im IT-Sicherheitsbereich so,
Ähm dann halte ich das für absolut ausgeschlossen, dass die Bundeswehr auch nur in die Nähe dessen kommen wird, diesen Personalbedarf äh zu decken. Ähm wenn ich mir weiterhin anschaue, um das so jetzt also.
Ich war ja 'ne längere Zeit auch für das Recruiting in einem Unternehmen zuständig,
Und ich hab ja gesehen, dass es ähm sagen wir mal relativ schwer ist da ähm kompetente Personen zu finden, die schon, sage ich mal, als geschliffener Diamant zu dir kommen,
du findest ähm viele Leute, wo du sagst, okay, denen kann man eine Chance geben,
Und dann entpuppen die sich entweder als ein großartiger Treffer und legen wahnsinnige Sachen hin oder eben nicht, aber die, die Bundeswehr geht hier ganz normal, ne? Weil die Bundeswehr geht hier hin und sagt, sie wollen,
Bereits erfolgte höhere Ausbildung haben, tausendachthundert Leute, wo sollen die näherkommen? Diese tausendachthundert Leute, wenn die sich bei Xing oder LinkedIn anmelden, kriegen zweimal die Woche ähm keine Ahnung, vierzig Jobs angeboten.
Zu ganz anderen Tarif.
Zu ganz anderen Tarifen ja. Das wird also nicht funktionieren. Ist also.
Sicherlich schwierig sein, über kurz oder lang müssen sie natürlich darüber nachdenken, wie sie quasi auch äh
junge Rekruten äh in der Hinsicht natürlich auch einen Ausbildungsweg bieten, wie sie das ja in den vielen anderen Disziplinen, die sie im militärischen Bereich brauchen, auch tun.
Wir werden also.
Das werden die, das, also die werden dann ähm wie die werden sich junge Rekruten holen müssen und die schulen müssen.
Das ist das ist und dann werden sie halt das können sie wahrscheinlich dann irgendwie Schweinegeld für Trainer ausgeben aus der freien Wirtschaft und die und irgendwie gucken, dass sie sich da eine Truppe aufbauen, aber tausendachthundert geschulte Kräfte innerhalb der nächsten zwei Jahre, boah.
Ich nicht hinkriege, also kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, geht nicht. Also das ist äh,
Es gibt, glaube ich, ähm andere andere Artikel auf Heize siehst du ja dann irgendwie der Fachkräftemangel, der Mangel, der dann irgendwie in Deutschland auf zehntausend beziffert wird oder sowas. Ich habe den Artikel jetzt gerade nicht zur Hand, aber da sind utopische
Fachkräftemangel in der Wirtschaft. Ja und dann sagen die, ja, wir brauchen mal eben achtzehnhundert und Bund zum Bund.
Wiss erstmal irgendwie die müssen ja auch durch die Acker.
Ja, es ist ja auch nicht so, dass das die einzigen wären, die äh Hacker suchen, sondern äh gibt ja auch noch andere Dienststellen, die äh da auch äh nachholbedarf haben.
Ähm ja, eigentlich eigentlich alle, ne? Also äh im Prinzip,
alle das äh gibt's jetzt also BND, Verfassungsschutz
Polizei, alle brauchen Hacker und haben ein Problem, ne? Ähm Hans-Georg Maaßen äh wird äh wird berichtet, der deshalb äh auf etwas anderes als Geld
IT-Fachleute anzulocken, nämlich den Reiz, ein Disverboten und lässt sich zitieren mit,
Er lässt sich zitieren mit wie er leuchten in den Augen von Neubewerbern sehe, wenn sie das Wort Server TKU hören,
also das Mitschneiden des Verkehrs der über einen Server läuft. Für IT-Spezialisten in der Privatwirtschaft ist das illegal. Bei Geheimdiensten aber Sankt Maaßen dürfe man seine Neugier auf diese Technik ausleben.
Den Spruch hat er ja schon mal gebracht in ähnlicher Form, ne? Ja sowas. Du weißt du noch.
Also warte mal. Warte mal. Ja, der hat die der war auch irgendwie sowas, ne?
Ja, ja, also hier dürfen sie auch Sachen machen, die.
Ein attraktiver.
Videoüberwachung und so. Von ja hier dürfen sehr viele Sachen machen, die irgendwie an der wo illegal sind, zum Beispiel Videoüberwachung, das war doch mal so ein Zit.
Nee, der hatte irgendwas anderes zum Beispiel, Videoabe, ja. Irgendwas anderes. Ja, der, der, das war so.
Telefonnummer, ich weiß gar nicht, o.
Überwachung oder so, ist der der Ahne hatte das auch in in seinen Songs irgendwie untergebracht mit den Krisennummer, glaube ich, ja, ja klar. Also der der virtuell, dass man da so und jetzt möchte ich eigentlich mal sagen,
Kann ich ja mal so ein bisschen zumindest aus dem Motivationsbereich sprechen, der den.
Ich sag mal zumindest ich habe und ich würde dann jetzt einfach mal sagen meinesgleichen ohne zu spezifizieren wer das ist, aber ich glaube es geht den meisten Leuten so.
Das Interessante am Hacken ist nicht irgendwelche Daten irgendwo rauszuholen,
Das Interessante ist, die Aufgabe zu lösen und quasi ein sportlicher Reiz an dieser Sache. Und es gibt nichts Langweiligeres,
als eine Server-TKÜ,
Ja, also es ist letztendlich du steckst da irgendwas zwischen und schreibst dir die, schreibst dir die Netzwerkpakete weg und nachher guckst du dir den Wire-Shark an,
bestenfalls hast du dann irgendwie deine eigenen Tools, um das irgendwie ein bisschen zu sortieren oder so oder du bist so super krass drauf und machst ein machst davor irgendein Proxi, der in Menden Mittelangriff macht
ja? Aber das ist doch nun wirklich, das ist äh das ist äh keine das ist ja keine reizvolle Aufgabe für jemanden, der der technisch interessiert ist,
Das ist einfach, das ist eine, also ganz ehrlich, jemand, der da leuchtenden Augen bekommt, den würde ich vorsichtig als pervers bezeichnen,
Das kann doch nicht ernsthaft etwas sein, wo du sagst, boah geil. Also ich meine, das ist irgendwie seit das ist,
hat nichts mit Forschung zu tun, das hat nichts mit Herausforderung zu tun, also fertige Tools, das dokumentierter äh Killfit, dann nimmst du irgendwie ähm Hackertools von der Stange.
Äh ich glaube schon, dass Leute gibt, die da einen leuchtenden Augen bekommen, äh aber ob das jetzt die Qualität von Leuten ist, die sie da brauchen und haben wollen, dass äh.
Wahrscheinlich schon. Wahrscheinlich ist es genau das, aber ähm also ganz ehrlich, ich glaube nicht, dass irgendwo jemand sitzt und sagt, also jemand, der sich jetzt technisch interessiert,
und technisch qualifiziert ist, der sagt, boah geil, das möchte ich aber unbedingt mal machen, irgendwo den Wireschack dranhalten. So, das kannst du ja,
Also sorry, ich meine, das ist wirklich nicht reizvoll und eher langweilig. Mus.
Langsam, aber ist doch gut, ist doch okay, aber ist doch gut, dass die Geheimdienste so einen guten Neumond haben in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Ja genau, das ist das wohl. Also ich habe mir auch gedacht, die wundern sich, die wundern sich, dass sie die Leute nicht kriegen, ne,
Und jetzt denk mal irgendwie nach, ne? Also einerseits wird das natürlich dann irgendwie auf die auf die auf den Chaos-Computerclub attribuiert, dass wir hier irgendwie so eine ähm,
so eine starke.
Vergraulungsstrategie fahren.
Nein, das wir eine starke Ehe, dass wir starke ethische Prinzipien vertreten
das irgendwie geschickt tun. Maaßen ähm habe ich ja auch mal bei so einer Veranstaltung gesehen, der sagt ja dann, also
der spricht ja, hatte ich auch glaube ich hier zitiert, der spricht ja dann von einer Datenschutzlobby und redet da irgendwie so von den Leuten, die so den ewig Gestrigen, die irgendwie in den Urteilen der siebziger Jahre verhaftet sind und nicht in der Neuzeit angekommen sind, in der es Computer gibt, so so redet der halt, ne, also versucht Datenschutz als antiquiert darzustellen oder oder den Anspruch,
an den Schutz des Individuums als irgendwie antiquierte Idee darzustellen, sei ihm ja gegönnt, kann er machen,
Und ich freue mich natürlich auch, wenn gesagt wird, dass Lägel a,
Am Chaos-Computerclub und seinen äh strengen ethischen Prinzipien, die wir hier, wie wir hier über Jahrzehnte die Hackerszene verdorben hätten, freue ich mich auch, wenn sowas gesagt wird, aber schau mal
Du hast irgendwie den den NSA und BND-Skandal.
Sind verdorben, ist ja auch gut. Ich meine.
Ja das war jetzt meine Wort.
Ja, wir weil wir waren ja auch lange Zeit einfach die einzige, die es gab, also ich warte, es ist so, das heißt, wenn ihr verdorben, also so so war sie halt.
Du hast jahrelang äh NSA und BND-Skandalen. Du hast einen Verfassungsverfassungsschutzskandal nach dem anderen,
Das ist ja nicht nur mit, dann guck dir diese ewigen Verquickungen und so weiter mit dem NSU an. Du hast ähm,
Mehr, ich weiß nicht, eine alle zwei Jahre zuverlässig äh Staatstrojanerskandale.
Und jetzt wundern die sich allen Ernstes, dass sie kein Personal finden. Wer hat denn Bock ähm bei diesem Arbeitgeber anzufangen.
Die haben einfach ihren öffentlichen Ruf dermaßen versaut,
ich glaube noch nicht mal mehr irgendein Schüler, der jetzt gerade nachwächst und vielleicht sogar sagt, gut, ich würde vielleicht gerne sogar das machen, ich hab
ich weiß es nicht, ich vielleicht sitzt da ja einer und sagt ich bin mittelmäßig begabt. Für mich ist so eine äh Server TKÜ schon spannend genug. Das ist ja, das kann ja auch spannender werden
ja, das kann ja auch technisch ähm interessant werden, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel so ein Torhin Service suchen musst,
dann bist du ruckzuck von einer von einer trivialen Aufgabe auf einmal in einer, wo du mit einem Team mehrere Wochen dranhängst und vielleicht ist das ja was, wo du echt sagst, so, das reizt mich, das ich habe dann auch das Gefühl, etwas Gutes zu tun.
Das kann ja sogar sein. Aber du meinst doch nicht ernsthaft, dass du bei so einem,
so einem ekeligen und unsympathischen Verein arbeiten möchtest, der einfach nur ähm Skandal Ridden ist, wie man sagt. Also es ist einfach, der ist durch. Da gibt's einfach ein Skandal nach dem anderen. Ja, dann äh hier.
Und und vor allem am laufenden Meter.
Am laufenden Meter.
Laufenden Meter von der Bundesregierung mit Etaterhöhung bestraft wird.
Und hast du, dann hast du äh na, Landesverrat habe ich jetzt noch außen vorgelassen, ne? Also es ist doch niemand so.
Na ja, also mit niemand ist relativ äh wir wissen, es gibt immer noch genug Leute, die sehen das anders.
Für ein mexikanisches Drogenkartell arbeiten. Die haben noch einen schlechteren.
Stimmt aber nichts.
Die haben schlechten Ruf tatsächlich. Musste überlegen. Nur die bei denen kannst du ja nicht aussuchen, ob er für die Arbeit ist oder nicht. So, aber da muss man so.
Andererseits äh dir die haben jetzt das Problem, dass sie inzwischen sich gegenseitig die Leute abwerben,
Also äh die Person, das die Personalgewinnung ist ein dermaßendes Problem, dass die äh,
Ja, sich gegenseitig die Leute abwerben und irgendwie der der Verfassungsschutz irgendeinen vom BND holt oder oder sowas, das äh,
Ist Methode und natürlich, dass sie intern schulen müssen. Und ich denke, das ist die einzige Strategie,
Äh die die für die aufgeben würde sich jetzt junge motivierte Leute zu holen, falls sie die finden,
Und denen eine erstklassige ähm eine eine erstklassige äh Ausbildung in diesem Bereich zu verschaffen.
Aber ich meine, du willst doch nicht ernsthaft heutzutage, also wenn du jetzt in die, in irgendwie in so einer, sagen wir mal, du bist mit deinem Informatiker Jahrgang,
Ne, du hast irgendwie Informatik studiert und jetzt ist irgendwie das erste Treffen und du musst nach fünf Jahren, dann sagt jeder, wo er jetzt arbeitet, ne,
dann willst du nicht derjenige sein, der sagt, ja ich bin beim Bund, da lachen die sich alle Schrott und und gucken irgendwie kurz auf ihren Porscheschlüssel.
Und lachen dich aus, ja?
Äh net war allererste mit äh sicherer, sicherer Arbeitsplatz ist nun mal auch für viele Leute so.
Haus im Grünen aber auch. Nein, aber also ne.
Bestimmte.
Du wirst dann halt, du wirst dann halt wegen der sagen wir mal auf dem Frei in der freien Wirtschaft aktuell nicht konkurrenzfähigen,
Gehalte oder wie heißt das sollt oder was oder Lohn oder wie wie auch immer das nennt, verlacht werden. Und außerdem natürlich wegen des schlechten Rufes. Wenn jetzt also Verfassungsschutz ist doch nun wirklich nicht was, wo du heute noch stolz drauf sein kannst, da zu arbeiten,
Das heißt nicht, dass du als Mitarbeiter des Verfassungsschutzes nicht vielleicht
in einer Abteilung arbeitest, die irgendwie eine wichtige Arbeit macht, die die ordentlich macht, äh die nicht mit Nazis kohl abiert ähm und die, die sich an irgendwie Recht und Gesetz hält und da trotzdem erstklassige Arbeit zum Schutz der der Verfassung.
Aber du hast doch trotzdem unter deinen unter deinen Kollegen und den Skandalen der Politik und deiner Vorgesetzten lange genug gelitten, dass du dein, dass du im Freundeskreis lieber sagst, wenn du arbeitest, äh am, was weiß ich,
Institut für Ironosphärenforschung oder sowas, ne? Also das ist doch, die haben doch den Ruf wirklich nachhaltig ruiniert.
Na ja, dann lebt sie's ja, wie wir wissen, gänzlich ungeniert.
Ja. Dann wurde ich äh äh möchte ich nochmal kurz ein bisschen einen kleinen, eine kleine Endote erzählen. Zu diesem Thema wurde ich interviewt.
Und zwar ähm relativ lang,
das ging ja, können wir da ein Telefoninterview zu führen. Und da habe ich gesagt, na, passen sie auf, so ein Telefoninterview,
dann rede ich eine dreiviertel Stunde, weil ich rede gerne und lang und am Ende machen sie daraus irgendwie so eine winzige Spalte mit einem Interview und ähm,
dann bin ich damit unglücklich. Stellen sie mir doch lieber ihre Fragen direkt,
Sagen sie, wie viel Zeichen ich antworten soll und dann gebe ich ihnen fertige Antworten, dann sparen wir uns diesen gesamten Ärger, ja? Also man spart sich eine Dreiviertelstunde telefonieren, man spart sich die nachherige Verschriftlichung, man spart sich darüber zu diskutieren, wer was gesagt hat. So ist für alle einfacher.
Ja, der will, das würden sie nicht so gerne machen und wollte dann lieber mit mir telefonieren. Da haben wir lange darüber geredet, dass ich so irgendwie über nationale Sicherheit und IT-Sicherheit gesprochen, meine Erwägung zu der Idee der Staatstrojaner, ne? Zitis
was ja irgendwie immer noch, das haben sie ja schön gespielt, immer noch irgendwie als die Fair und Entschlüsselungsbehörde gesehen wird, obwohl das am Ende die die Hacking und Staatstrojaner,
Abteilung für die für die Strafverfolgung sein wird, aber all das, ja, da haben wir lange drüber geredet. Und am Ende irgendwann in diesem Interview sagt er dann irgendwann, ja.
Denken sie nicht auch so und so. Und dann habe ich gesagt, nee, denke ich nicht. Das kann man so sagen, aber.
Und genau diesen Satz, der eindeutig von diesem Interviewer stammt, finde ich nachher natürlich in der Niederschrift des Interviews. Dann habe ich den rausgestrichen, habe gesagt, hier, ne, kommt raus.
Und ähm,
kriege ich irgendwie so als Antwort ja ähm von diesem Satz würde ich stark abraten, das ist wolkiger Politiker spreche, wie wir ihn eigentlich zu vermeiden versuchen,
was den Rest angeht, bemühe ich mich ihren Wünschen gerecht zu werden, habe ich nochmal gesagt, habe ich nochmal geschrieben, gesagt, ich weiß, dass der Satz ihnen gefällt, aber er war leider nicht meine Antwort auf ihre Frage,
ich den Satz so nicht gesagt habe, habe ich ihn auch vollständig ersetzt, du musst leider darauf bestehen,
Ja, aber äh das ist leider das Schwierige bei schriftlichen Antworten, das klingt so nach Politikersprech ähm vielleicht könnte ich ja äh ich will ja keine Worte in den Mund legen. Schreibt der Journalist sogar noch, ne?
Aber schauen Sie sich doch mal an, dass dieser Satz, den ich da geschrieben habe, eigentlich viel schöner ist und inhaltlich ist er ja auch sehr nah dran. Vielleicht kann ich sie ja doch noch überzeugen, äh sich da auf eine konkrete Ausdrucksweise festnageln zu lassen. Im Sinne der obigen Obing-Formulierung.
Ähm.
Unglaublich.
Unglaublich, ne? Und du weißt, dass ich hier letzte Woche mit dir gesessen habe,
und dir das erzählt habe und gesagt hab, was mache ich denn jetzt da, ne? Dann habe ich nicht mehr geantwortet. Das Ding ist so auch rausgekommen, wurde gedruck.
Wenn kam, wenn ich keine Antwort mehr von ihnen erhalte, belaste ich es, so wie es ist.
So und dann habe ich äh dann habe ich geschrieben, entschuldigen sie mal bitte, ne? Ich habe das hier irgendwie mehrmals angemerkt, dass ich diese Äußerung nicht getätigt habe. Da habe ich einfach nicht, ne? Und ähm ja, aber wäre doch so schön, ne,
Dann wurde mir angeboten, ja man könnte ja jetzt rausnehmen mit Hinweis, dass das Interview verändert wurde, habe ich auch gesagt, Freunde
Ich mache mich doch jetzt nicht irgendwie, lass mich doch nicht erst von euch mir erst von euch eine eine Äußerung in den Mund legen und mich dann auf alle Ewigkeit im Internet festhalten, als jemand, der nachher ein Interview redigiert, ich habe euch hundert Mal vorher geschrieben,
Also fand ich echt unmöglich und ähm bin da am Ende der Satz selber ist noch nicht mal so tragisch, ja? Ich habe jetzt.
Eine Stilfrage, wie man einfach sowas auch äh.
So, aber ich war von dem von dem von dem Stil wirklich massiv enttäuscht und zwingt mich jetzt, was ich auch wirklich ärgerlich finde in Zukunft solche Interviews entweder überhaupt nicht mehr mündlich mit Journalisten zu führen
Ähm oder eben das aufzuzeichnen und zu sagen, okay, ich zeichne das auf, wenn ihr mir nachher irgendwelche Worte in den Mund legt, die ich nicht gesagt habe, ähm bin ich nächstes Mal frei.
So mache ich das übrigens, äh ich ich mache zum Beispiel gar nichts per Text.
Ich hab auch schon öfter so zu anderen Themen natürlich, ne? Anfrage mir ist abgesehen davon, dass mir das auch zu viel Arbeit ist das alles runterzutippen und ich sowieso sehr viel besser so aus dem Kopf heraus einfach antworten kann,
und dann ist er mal der Zeitbedarf klar. Ich meine, du wolltest eine Dreiviertelstunde ersparen, wie viel Zeit hast du da jetzt.
Stunden am Ende. Ja und alter auch ein riesen Ärger, ne? Also ich finde das also ich muss sagen, ich persönlich.
Muss ja jetzt auch diesen diesen Journalisten, der mich da interviewt hat, zugute halten, der meinte das sehr gut. Der bewahr wohlmeinend, das war ein freundlicher Mensch,
der wirklich man hat gemerkt der wollte mir dazu verhelfen eine irgendwie eine klare Position da zu vertreten und mir zu einem Interview verhelfen was sag ich mal.
Leute zum Nachdenken bringt. Er hatte wirklich,
Der hätte zu keinem Zeitpunkt eine böse Absicht, der war stets bemüht, muss ich wirklich sagen. Ähm das war, kann ich nicht als bösartig empfehlen. Was war, weshalb ich das noch viel krasser finde, weil ich eigentlich auch überrascht war, dass mir und das passiert mir tatsächlich nicht,
ich interviewed werdet, also es passiert mal, dass jemand sagt, wenn man den Satz, ganz ehrlich, muss das sein, kann man das nicht kürzer machen oder ähm.
Mhm. Oder? So aus praktischen Erwägungen.
Aktiven Erwägungen, aber ähm im Prinzip finde ich schon überrascht, wenn mir dann gesagt wird,
In diesem Fall ging es eben auch um meine Meinung, ne? Und ähm so jetzt irgendwie Beratung, wie ich mein Interview führe von dem Interviewer zu bekommen, fand ich dann, also fand ich ein bisschen als eine grenzüberschreitung in der,
In dem was ich von einem Journalisten erwartet hätte. Ja ähm,
Trotzdem muss ich sagen, der Jutemann hat es gut gemeint, der zwar nicht böse gemeint, wir haben uns da am Ende leidenschaftlich drüber gezankt, der war auch glaube ich überrascht, dass ich da ähm dann doch so knatschig war.
Und der Schaden ist nicht groß, aber ich war tatsächlich einfach überrascht, weil ich meine, ich gebe eigentlich relativ häufig Interviews und sowas ist mir,
In der Form noch nicht so wirklich passiert. Was passiert ist, dass man dann also bei Fernsehinterviews bricht sie fünfmal ab und darfst du nochmal machen. Dann sagt, dann kommt auch sowas, dass denn
Wie gesagt wird, na ja, pass auf, wenn du den Satz noch kürzer hinkriegst
Und fünf Nebensätze mal rauskürzt, dann gebe ich, dann kann ich den verwenden. So ist er zu lang. Das ist natürlich arbeitet man da zusammen. Also der, das ist immer eine eine schmale Planke. Aber da habe ich mich jetzt ähm,
Habe ich mich mal drüber geärgert. Na ja. Trotzdem ähm die Berichterstattung zu dem Thema ist breit und ähm,
Auch wenn ich, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, ich finde das natürlich mich,
füllt das auf eine gewisse Weise mit Freude, dass diese Institutionen Probleme haben, Personal zu finden. Sowohl das Militär ähm als auch äh Verfassungsschutz und sonstige. Ähm.
Ich freue mich auch, dass man das irgendwie dem CCC zurechnet, wobei ich glaube, dass der CC, wenn dann da eine relativ geringe Rolle spielt, ähm weil wir ja nicht die einzige,
NGO sind, aber immerhin, wir achten darauf, dass äh dass die Leute, die die bei uns aufwachsen ähm,
und von uns ähm vielleicht lernen oder was heißt von uns lernen oder im Chaos, Computerclub sozialisiert werden, Kenntnisse erlangen, lernen, äh dass die einen vernünftigen, ethisch, moralischen Kompass direkt noch mitvermittelt bekommen. Das freut mich natürlich auch.
Ich glaube aber ehrlich gesagt, dass äh diese Institution mehr unter ihrem eigenen Ruf leiden als als unter uns.
Kommen wir äh kommen wir in,
In dem Bereich ähm der Netzwirtschaft und äh schlechten Ideen, die aus den USA kommen.
Du hast es nämlich, ich habe das heute Morgen gesucht ähm wir haben darüber lang und rabreit berichtet und ich konnte es nicht finden diese der die USA haben das ja auch gemeint die deutsche Telekom US.
Team Mobile.
Deswegen habe ich das nicht gefunden.
Weil es Team Morweil heißt bei denen.
Nach nicht Telekom. Also ich glaube so verwenden sogar diesen Namen, ne? Dieses Stream-On. Also worum geht's denn jetzt.
Ja, das hieß da auch äh Binch One hieß das bei den Binge on.
Bin ich na ja,
Tja, ja. Ja, also es geht um Netzneutralität und es geht um die deutsche Telekom. Ja äh hatten wir ja auch schon mal darüber berichtet. Es gab ja mal diese Spotify, Flatrate bei der Telekom,
wo man dann quasi äh wenn man Spotify-Dienste nutzt, sprich sich da halt Audio-Streaming zukommen lässt, äh entweder im eigenen Account oder mit diesem,
damaligen Freien äh äh Dienst, also gibt's ja auch immer noch so freie mit Werbung et cetera. Wenn man das also macht, dann geht es eben nicht auf den eigenen äh,
Daten auf das eigene Datenvolumen, sondern läuft halt einfach mal so nebenbei, ne? Das Zero-Rating ist ja auch generell in der Kritik äh und es betrifft auch nicht nur ähm hochkommerzielle Institutionen, sondern,
unter anderem ja auch die Wikipedia, die ja teilweise bei solchen Projekten mitgemacht hat äh aus.
Nachvollziehbaren Gründen, ne? Weil sie ja sozusagen.
Der Welt, das freie Wissen zukommen lassen wollen.
Aber das erzeugt dann auch mal wieder kollateralschaden, aber jetzt ist ja dieser Spotify-Dienst dann wieder eingestellt worden, nachdem wir in Europa äh ja doch zumindest eine äh gute Grundeinigung auf Netzneutralität bekommen haben.
Der wurde aber der wurde vor allem glaube ich schon im August letzten Jahres eingestellt, einfach weil sie gesagt haben, die Leute nutzen das zu sehr, ne? Also der wurde,
War die Shit, die machen das ja ernsthaft, das müssen wir jetzt mal wieder abschalten. War, glaube ich, die offizielle Begründung, aber.
Da wo kommen wir denn da hin, wenn die Leute auch.
Nein, wenn die Leute das n.
Dienste noch benutzen und die Verträge äh so benutzen, wie es drin steht. Ja und jetzt wollen sie wieder neu äh einen neuen Vorstoß starten, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja, die haben, die haben magenta eins, zehn Punkt null gelauncht. Ich denke, die werden zehn Punkt null.
Können wir der Wirtschaft bitte mal diese Versionsnummern wegnehmen.
Also wenn die so weitermachen überholt Magenta bald die Linux in der Versionierung.
Vagenta eins zehn Punkt null. Eins Punkt zehn für Workgroups. Ähm.
Ach Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, das ist doch immer noch irgendwie DSL drei elf.
Da heißt es jetzt Stream on.
Und ja wollen sie also jetzt äh im Mobilfunkbereich das Videostreaming ähm aus dem Datenvolumen ausnehmen und kostenlos machen,
Und.
Das natürlich nur bei Partnern. Und sie sagen, das steht aber jedem Unternehmen frei äh sich äh an dem Dienst zu beteiligen. Da wird niemand diskriminiert oder ausgeschlossen,
dann fragt man sich, dann macht es doch einfach so, dann wisst ihr doch nicht, mit den wisst ihr doch nicht mit den mit den Unternehmen reden.
Also genau das, ne, dass jetzt Unternehmen.
Sicher einkaufen können.
Ja, es steht hier frei, das ist ungefähr so, ne, wenn du sagst, äh wir verkaufen unsere Produkte an jeden, da wird keiner diskriminiert,
absoluter Unsinn, dass wir hier Leute diskriminieren würden. Wir verkaufen unser, das kann jeder, ist ein freier Markt, kann jeder kaufen, was wir hier haben, in beide Richtungen eben, ne. Ähm die Bundesnetzagentur,
prüft das und sagt, okay, wollen wir schauen, ob das äh ob das akzeptabel ist. Und wir erinnern uns aber, die EU-Regulation verbietet so etwas
nicht. Das war der letzte wichtige Punkt, den der äh den Thomas Lohninger damals in seinem äh in den Sendungen und die ganz Edri und sonst was EU-Gruppen, die da für den jetzt Neutralität gekämpft haben. Ähm,
hatten Zero Rating in dieser Form per se nicht hundertprozentig ausgeschlossen.
Die erste Pressemitteilung, die ich dazu gesehen habe, jetzt von einer NGO kam von D vierundsechzig, die war relativ selten zitieren, insofern ist das umso besser. Da haben wir Henning Tillmann, der sagt
Stadt Zero Rating müssen Mobilfunkanbieter ihr Datenvolumen erhöhen und die Gängelung der Nutzerinnen und Nutzer durch Zero Rating unterbinden,
Ähm ist ja total richtig, ne? Also dann gibt uns doch dann erhöht doch einfach das Datenvolumen, dann kommen wir doch klar. Wir brauchen so etwas ja gar nicht. Wenn ihr einfach mal normales Datenvolumen anbietet.
Was ja in Deutschland auch immer noch ziemlich unterirdisch ist. Also.
Ist immer noch total wenig und äh also es ist alles eines ganz schlimm. Aber dann gebt gib den Leuten doch einfach mehr Volumen, dann können sie's nutzen, wofür sie wollen, ist doch alles gut. Erzählt doch nicht, dass und vor allem ausgerechnet Videostreaming
das eine Problem ist, was die Leute haben, ne? Also was die Netzanbieter haben. Video-Streaming ist so eine richtige Drecksau,
nimmt am meisten Traffic weg, hat diese Echtzeitanforderung
Das ist das, was dir eigentlich Kopfschmerzen macht, alles andere, kommen ist egal. Ähm ob das jetzt eine Sekunde schneller oder langsamer ist, da werden die Kunden nicht unglücklich, ne? Musik, Streaming, viel geringere Bandbreite, kriegst du auch noch durchgepresst.
Lot. Ich meine, dafür würden sie sich ja dann auch explizit bezahlen lassen sozusagen.
Genau und sie werden sich bezahlen lassen natürlich. Also L vierundsechzig sagt weiter wie das politisch umgesetzt werden kann, hat die Niederlande vorgemacht mit großer Mehrheit hat sie im Oktober
zweitausendsechzehn ein Verbot von Zero Rating verabschiedet, fertig, also vorgefordert werden muss jetzt ein,
Gesetzliches nationales Verbot durch den Bundestag.
Nur nochmal falls die Leute sich wundern, dass wir uns gerade darüber aufregen, dass sie äh ab dem neunzehnten vierten kostenloses Videostreaming bei ausgewählten Anbietern Sternchen bis zu haben. Ähm das Problem ist natürlich, dass es eine Reihe an Anbietern gibt, die davon ausgeschlossen sind und
dass die Anbieter, die bei euch
kostenlos dann im Datenvolumen vom Datenvolumen ausgenommen werden, dafür bezahlen und das ist eben eine eine Kartellbildung im Prinzip zwischen demjenigen, der euch das Internet gibt und demjenigen, der euch über das Internet etwas anbietet,
Zum Nachteil, anderer, die euch über das Internet etwas anbieten und das ist äh wirklich nicht das, was wir haben möchten in diesem Netz,
Wir haben jetzt schon den Krieg da drin. Jetzt brauchen wir nicht auch noch irgendwie die Kartelle.
Ja müssen wir mal schauen äh Bundesregierung und was verabschieden äh in dieser Legislaturperiode.
Auch wenn die wollen, können die ganz flott. Wenn die wollen, können die ganz flott.
Tja, das sehen wir noch.
Das geht aber Rucki zucki, wenn die was verabschieden wollen. Man tut, man denkt sich immer so, ach, da schaffen die doch nicht mehr dieses Jahr, das oder diese diese vier, in diesen vier Jahren schaffen die das doch nicht mehr. Nee, geht ganz, ganz flott. Und zwar machen wir es ja immer äh folgendermaßen
Was jetzt seit längerer Zeit läuft ist eine Reform des Strafprozessrechts,
diese Reform des Strafprozessrechts steht jetzt kurz vor der Verabschiedung
Da werden sie viele Dinge geregelt. Äh unter anderem, ob jetzt wie Vernehmungen aufgezeichnet werden, ne? Wenn jetzt jemand verwört wird oder so. Alles Mögliche. Und jetzt ganz zackig, ganz mal eben schnell noch mit drin
ist Staatstrojaner Einsatz.
Jetzt fragte er, wen fragen sich die äh Leute natürlich, ja wie Staatsrealer Einsatz ist doch schon im BKA-Gesetz geregelt? Richtig, für das BK, ne? Das BKA ist ja für die schweren äh Straftaten zuständig, ne. Terrorismus und hast du alles nicht gesehen, dass BKA darf, laut BKA-Gesetz in bestimmten strengen Grenzen
ein Staatstrainer einsetzen, aber was ist mit der Feldwald- und Wiesenpolizei,
Was ist mit äh mit mit Fahrraddiebstahl? Ja, da kann ja so ein Staatstrianer auch helfen
oder Beispiel, dass Andre Meis hatte, was weiß ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Handel mit Anabolika oder irgendwelche Scherze, die sage ich mal, deren gesellschaftlicher Schaden dann doch eher,
Geringer ist als der von Terrorismus.
Da bleibt das Problem, die Ermächtigungsgrundlage. Ermächtigungsgrundlage heißt, es gibt ein es muss ein Gesetz geben, was das erlaubt. Und die Argumentation der Vergangenheit war ja immer neuer. Wir haben ja ein TKÜ-Gesetz, wo drin steht, man darf TKÜ machen,
Und das reicht aus, diese Grundlage. Andere, die ein bisschen sich mit der Technik auseinandergesetzt haben, sagen natürlich, na ja, du begehst aber eine Verletzung der Integrität des Gerätes,
und machst viel, viel mehr als nur eine äh kannst viel mehr machen als nur eine Kommunikationsüberwachung aus diesem Grund brauchst, ist es verfassungsrechtlich nicht in Ordnung, du brauchst wenn.
In eine eigene Ermächtigungsrundlage, die dir das explizit genehmigt. Und die.
Brauchen sie jetzt und die haben sie jetzt schnell in die Strafprozessordnung oder dieses Strafprozessordnungsreform äh mit reingemogelt. Denn das hat ja bei der Datenhelerei und der Vorderzeitenspeicherung auch schon so gut geklappt,
Im letzten Moment so.
Einfach mal was mit reinschreiben.
So, letzter Moment haben wir lange darüber geredet, alles klar, dann schieben wir das noch kurz mit rein, ne? So, können wir jetzt abstimmen, ne? War gar kein Problem. Kleine Änderung. So in Ordnung, ne? Kein.
Kleine Erinnerung. So in Ordnung, ne? Ist eigentlich nur Komba-Sitzung. Hier ein kleines Komma geändert. Ja.
Hier kleines Komma geändert so. Ach jetzt zack, wollten wir doch eh immer. Ja und das ist.
Also man muss sich das mal so reinziehen, ne? Wie viele Jahre diskutieren wir jetzt über diese Staatstrojaner? Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wann das erste
mal das so viele Jahre her, dass Andreas Burg damals vorm Bundesverfassungsgericht war und dann kam das um zwanzig elf war dann der Staatstrojaner und die entsprechenden Skandale, die da rauskamen und an BKA gesetzt und
Dieses Thema wird so lange behandelt und immer wieder war der Gegenwind.
Ja, aber das geht doch hier um um Terrorismus. Das geht doch hier um, ne, um um schwerste Straftaten, da mussten müssen doch selbst die Hacker äh.
An die Kinder.
An die Kinder und die Terroristen und so und nur schwerste Straftaten und es ist,
immer so, dass es dann im nächsten Moment aufgeweicht wird. Dieser, dieses Problem des Damm oder dieses dieser dieses Phänomen des Dammbruchs, was bei jedem derartigen Scheiß,
von den,
der Netzcommunity oder den äh Grundrechtlern oder wie man auch immer sie bezeichnen möchte oder den ewig gestrigen Datenschützern, ja, angebracht wird. Es ist immer richtig. Es trifft zu, es passiert einfach.
Und ähm es ist einfach, es ist eingeplant. Es sind ja immer noch die gleichen Hampelmänner.
So, das ist strategie, also ist taktisch von vornherein vorgesehen, das kann man also ne, es wäre jetzt wirklich ein Witz zu zu
wenn Heiko Maas aus
so die die Story so ungefähr wäre, ach im letzten Mist ist mir aufgefallen, hat sie jetzt kurzfristig ergeben, müssen wir noch äh mit in die äh in diese Reform mit aufnehmen
nicht etwa das seit langer Hand
plant war zu sagen, okay, im letzten Moment schieben wir das mal mit rein, dann dann peitschen wir das schnell durch. Wird keiner großartig was gegen haben, die schaffen's nicht ihren ihren Widerstand zu formieren und der Drops ist gelutscht,
so läuft das. Und dann muss man doch auch einfach mal sagen wer denn äh wer denn so etwas macht,
Das ist unser Freund Heiko Maas,
Natürlich kommt eine ähm Reform des des Strafprozessrechts vom Justizministerium, ne? Ist ja Justiz.
Und Heiko Maas ist da ja äh Wiederholungstäter in diesem Bereich, ne? Der hat das, ich hatte das gerade schon erwähnt, Datenhederei und äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Aber das war doch alles nur Unfälle, das war doch alles gar nicht so beabsichtigt. Das war immer hat es nicht beabsichtigt. Mhm.
Das war immer alles nicht beabsichtigt. Also ähm.
Kommt bloß ziemlich oft vor.
Ich genau passiert relativ oft, dass der irgendwie was vergisst und im letzten Moment noch reinschiebt, ne? Und ähm oder also oder auch einfach versprechen bricht, ja,
Hier wird's keine Vorortsheimschweichung geben oder Schwarzwärter so. Also das ist wirklich hinter und ich muss sagen.
Warum ich das, warum ich das so hier betone, ist, weil der wenn der redet.
Ein ziemlich nachdenklichen und klugen Eindruck macht und sogar.
Ich muss es sagen, auf mich ein sehr sympathischen. Ich habe, wenn man den so vom Typen, wenn man den sieht, hat man nicht den Eindruck, dass das ein schlechter Mensch ist.
Krasse schon seine Telefonnummer.
Nee, dann ruft er mich nachher noch an.
Oder bin ein Interview.
Oder schickt mir einen Staatstrojaner,
Aber wie der, wie der das macht, ist wirklich eine, da muss man, also ganz ehrlich, so wie dieser Minister agiert, musst du dich auch nicht wundern, wenn den Leuten irgendwann äh.
Wenn die Leute irgendwann keinen Bock mehr haben auf solche Politiker. Weil das, was er macht, ist einfach unaufrichtig,
unaufrichtiger ähm Stil,
Ne, die Leute arg lässt sich zu täuschen mit Verfahrenstricks Gesetze durchzuboxen in letzter Minute Änderungen vorzunehmen. In der letzten Woche haben wir ja noch darüber gesprochen. Ist ja auch wieder sowas vorgelaufen bei dem äh Netzwerk durch äh Durchsetzungsgesetz.
Wo ich jetzt auch nochmal kurz was zu sagen wollte.
Ja, dass äh da sieht's ja auch nach einem entsprechenden ja legalen Fail aus.
Ne
also zwei Probleme, um das noch kurz aus der letzten Sendung nochmal zu rekapitulieren. Erstens, die Entscheidung darüber, was ein legaler oder illegaler Inhalt ist, wird einfach in die Hand der Plattformbetreiber gelegt und äh die werden dann
es ist einfach ganz normale Folge davon, dass die lieber zu viel als zu wenig löschen.
Weil Wettersafe sind, sorry.
Das viel größere Problem äh und ich ist die Bestandsdatenauskunft, ja? Also mal eben flott wem gehört dieser IP, alles klar, äh Abmahnen, fertigmachen, äh,
Anzeigen oder sonst was, ne? Also haben wir schon in der letzten Woche herausgearbeitet. Bestandsdaten,
Auskünfte sind das, was Abmahner antreibt und das soll in diesem Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz,
ähm verankert werden, auch für die zivilrechtlichen Auseinandersetzungen und dann bist du im Ruckzuck ähm bei Abmahnungen für schlechte Bewertungen, bei Abmahnungen, für alle möglichen Scherze.
Beleidigungen.
So, jetzt dann liest du heute nach Spiegelinformationen,
hat Maaß Ministerium auf die massive Kritik der vergangenen Tage reagiert und eine entscheidende Passus für den Beschluss im Kabinett abgeändert. Das lesen wir an dem Tag, wo die das beschlossen haben im Kabinett,
Das heißt, Spiegel Online liegt vor, was dieses was das Kabinett jetzt beschlossen hat, als als Vorlage. Dem,
der Allgemeinheit aber nicht,
Also auch wieder so, ne? Also dahinter steckt wieder Heiko Maas, ne? Wird am letzten Tag noch was geändert. Da wird jetzt im Kabinett gemacht und dann liegt es Spiegel online vor und Spiegel online zitiert nur Teile daraus
So entstehen unsere Kabinettsvorlagen und Gesetz. Klar, das geht jetzt nochmal, das wird ja dann herabgereicht in den Bundestag und so weiter, ne. Aber ähm was ist das denn für ein Stil
Da musst du dich doch echt nicht wundern, wenn die Leute sagen, äh sie haben keinen Bock mehr auf auf solche Politiker. Ganz ehrlich, muss sich echt nicht wundern, lieber Heiko.
Na ja, die Änderung ist, dass sie sagen, ähm.
Wenn es in Richtung Bußgelder gehen soll, also das Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz macht ja Bußgelder im Falle von ja schon. Sie sagen in der Regel nicht bereits durch einen einmaligen Verstoß soll das passieren,
wenn du also irgendwie einmal gegen diese Pflicht verstößt oder so was, ne? Oder irgendwas stehen lässt, ähm dass im Graubereich ist ähm,
Wenn du jetzt also ein offensichtlich rechtfriedenen Inhalt nicht innerhalb von vierundzwanzig Stunden gelöscht hast, beim erstmaligen Verstoß ist das, kriegst du jetzt nicht die volle Strafe äh volle Härte des Gesetzes.
Ähm also genau, innerhalb von vierundzwanzig Stunden bei ähm bei ähm,
Beschwerde oder innerhalb von sieben Tagen ohne Beschwerde. Ähm bei einem einmaligen Verstoß können nämlich rechtmäßig,
Noch regelmäßig noch nicht davon ausgegangen werden, dass,
Kein wirksames Verfahren für den Umgang mit Schwerden über rechtswidrige Inhalte bestehe und das ist das, was sie bestrafen wollen. Also sie wollen sich dazu sie wollen nicht ja dazu drängen, ein wirksames Verfahren zu etablieren für den Umgang mit Rechtswidrigen Inhalten,
Das wiederum heißt beim zweiten Mal kriegst du eine Strafe, das wiederum heißt das ändert überhaupt nichts. Du kriegst trotzdem, ne? Du musst trotzdem ein wirksames Verfahren für den Umgang mit äh mit Beschwerden über rechtswidrige Inhalte haben und das heißt, dann löscht es halt bei der nächsten Beschwerde.
Weiterhin sagen sie in der Vorlage, dass in Fällen, in denen ein soziales Netzwerk einen illegalen Inhalt nicht als Gesetz rechtswidrig einschätzt,
Zum Schutz der Meinungsfreiheit ein behutsames Vorgehen der Bußgeldbehörde angezeigt ist. Weil es im Prinzip das finde ich immer so witzig, dass sie da das Kernproblem benennen, nämlich das Facebook das nicht als rechtswidrig einschätzt.
Dann sagen sie in dem Fall muss das, muss die Bußgeldbehörde dann eben behutsam vorgehen. Als wenn die sich nachher dafür interessiert, das steht doch am Ende eh in der ähm.
In der Kommentierung nicht im Gesetz.
Also wonach es also aussieht mit diesem Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ist das da erstmal nichts durchgesetzt wird auf der einen Seite, aber auf der anderen Seite,
Dieser Punkt mit der Bestandsdatenauskunft soweit aufgeweicht wird, dass es uns sogar passieren kann, dass jetzt Daten von Providern herausgegeben werden müssen,
ohne dass er ein Gericht äh Beschluss vorliegt einfach nur, weil jemand sagt, ja hier, ja, mich hat er beleidigt, ich möchte ja gerne zivilrechtlich gegen vorgehend Mandaten.
So hat sich das letzte gelesen, weiß ich, kann ja sein, dass sich der Kabinettsbeschluss der jetzt da heute entschieden wurde, geändert hat. Das kann sein, Tim. Da kann sich viel ändern, weiß man ja nicht, sieht man ja nicht.
Das geht über jedes Maß hinaus. Und ich muss sagen, der der Maß ist eine, also ist einfach eine große Enttäuschung. So, wer ich meine, also der macht was. Im Moment ist er gerade in den Medien und und will die Kinderehe verbieten.
Hast du das mitbekommen, Kinderesa verboten werden? Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich dachte, das wäre verboten, haben meine Eltern mir äh als kleines Kind schon Ätzte erklärt, als ich heiraten wollte. Haben die gesagt, Kinderehe ist verboten.
Jetzt kommt Heiko Maas und, und, und, sagt, jetzt aber endlich, jetzt verbieten wir das. Hm? Es gab lange, lange Diskussionen äh über dieses diese äh,
nein heißt nein Gesetze da wo dann jetzt auf einmal die Vergewaltigung verboten wurde. Nein das soll also,
Da kann man dann also das ist nicht mein Fachbereich, kann ich nicht äh kann ich nicht äh,
nichts zu sagen, aber ähm es war auf jeden Fall so, dass wir, dass wir, dass das Feuer auch schon verboten war, habe ich mir versichern lassen und ähm äh wenn man sich da die Einlassung von dem BGH Richter Thomas Fischer Zoo mal durchliest, also die fachlichen
Ähm dann äh sieht man da auch einen anderen Eindruck. Dann
haben wir von Maas die Vorratsdatenspeicherung bekommen, entgegen der Versprechen löst er jetzt die Anonymität im Internet äh vollständig auf mit diesem Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz und gibt uns den Staatstrojaner für alle,
Aber ein dieser netter Typ und jedes Mal, na, nicht jedes Mal bei der, bei diesem, nein, als deine Gesetzgebung, glaube ich, nicht. Aber ansonsten eigentlich immer,
Also wenn's um Grundrechte geht, immer mit Verfahrenstricks und bei Nacht und Nebel.
Ja, ist beunruhigend.
Deine eine schöne Formulierung äh er gehört am Wochenende, aber die kann ich dir nicht sagen. Ganz linke Type ist das, eine ganz linke Type.
Ach ja.
In over News für äh diejenigen.
Nicht ausreichend beunruhigt sind.
Ähm Kennzeichenerfassung an der Grenze gibt's jetzt, ja? Also die Bundespolizei darf ähm,
Zumindest vorübergehend
auch ohne Wissen der betroffenen automatisch an Grenzen äh Kennzeichen äh speichern und erfassen, um eben zu gucken, wer waren über die Grenze gefahren ist mit anderen Worten, äh wer irgendwie jetzt regelmäßig,
nach Holland fährt oder so für einen Kurzbesuch, der kann davon ausgehen, dass sich das demnächst in Datenbanken der Bundespolizei finden lässt.
Und vor allem.
Polen oder werden viele andere.
Weiß es jetzt nicht genau, aber ich vermute mal,
An der Grenze heißt so viel wie im Grenzbereich Grenzhundgebiet, also das ist sozusagen vermutlich dieser Bereich, den auch der Zoll sozusagen
äh wahrnimmt. Das ist dann eben nicht nur an der Grenze und hinter dem Schlagbaum, sondern das ist dann.
Nee, das ist also wenn ich.
An verschiedensten Ein- und Ausfahrtsstraßen, aber das kann er halt auch mal fünf bis zehn Kilometer ins Land hinein sein.
Das weiß ich nicht hundertprozentig. Ich kenne nur ich kenne eine fixe Anlage, die ähm äh die auf die ich mal hingewiesen wurde auf dem Weg nach Polen und die war dann so im Prinzip einfach auf der Autobahn,
Ab dem Punkt, wo du nichts anderes mehr machen kannst, als über die Grenze zu fahren, ne? Also wo, wo einfach klar ist, letzte Ausfahrt ist vorbei. Jetzt geht's ab nach Polen, ob du willst oder nicht. Äh da stand das Ding dann. Wenn ich mich recht entzinne. Aber sowas gibt's natürlich auch mobil, ne? Machst du einfach äh,
blitzt einem im Prinzip einfach jedes Auto, kurze Erkennung auf das Kennzeichen und.
Wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal groß blitzen. Ich denke irgendwie Smartphone aus dem Fenster halten.
Ja, die die werden sich.
Heute auch schon ausreichen, ne?
Anlagen für Bauna, aber wunderbar, ne? Das heißt also jetzt ne äh schön.
Schönes Schengen, was wir da jetzt haben. Kannst jetzt in den, kannst du deine Nummernschilder fotografieren lassen. So war das nur am Rande, hat jetzt nicht viel zu tun, aber wollen wir auch mal erzählen.
Das bestimmt nur wegen der bösen Engländer, damit die dann irgendwie nicht mehr in die EU dürfen.
Der andere war noch ein interessantes Urteil zum zum Fallsharing, äh dass wir ja als Public Service Innouncement nochmal äh kurz äh wiedergeben. Also Fall war folgender.
Es wurde irgendein ähm Musikalbum per Tourent geteilt. Irgendwie Rihanna oder oder was weiß der Geier, irgend so eine,
Sängerin, ne? Aktuelles Album wurde wurde wurde über Fallsharing geteilt. Dann wissen wir ja, die Abmahn
Die Abmahner sind selber mit in dem Toren drin, Protolokolieren einfach alle IP-Adressen, äh machen dann eine Bestandsdatenauskunft und versenden ihre Serienbriefe mit der Kostennote. An alle, die in diesem Tor drin waren und
dann ähm kannst du eben sagen, kannst ja im Prinzip zahlen. Seit sagten die Eltern.
Also die Anschlussinhaber ähm ja wir waren das nicht wir kennen aber den wahren Täter in der Familie.
Sagen aber nicht, wer das war. Und wir haben drei Kinder.
So war der Sachverhalt. Und das Ganze ist vor den ähm BGH gegangen, wenn ich mich jetzt hier nicht täusche? Nee, äh Oberlandesgericht München, das Oberlandesgericht München urteilte dann. Na ja, du bist nicht,
Zu konkreten Nachforschungen innerhalb der Familie verpflichtet. Also du musst nicht rausfinden, welches deiner drei Kinder es war,
Aber wenn du es weißt dann musst du den auch benennen.
Und ähm wenn du den nicht kennst, dann bist du von der Haftung befreit. Ähm.
Das heißt, es waren etwas unkluge Äußerungen, die die da getätigt haben.
Der genau, der Bundes der BGH hatte nämlich vor kurzem entschieden, dass die Eltern nicht die Computer der Kinder oder Ehegatten durchsuchen müssen. Also ne, du bist jetzt was weiß ich
Bis das Oberhaupt der Familie. Ähm jetzt kommt der kommt die Abmahnung und du fragst erstmal deinen Mann,
ob der das war oder deine oder und deine zwei Kinder.
So und jetzt äh sagen die alle, ne, war ich nicht oder äh oder einer eines eines der Familienmitglieder sagt, ja Scheiße, hey, Kacke.
Und das musst du aber nicht machen. Du musst da nicht, du musst oder wenn du, du musst da nicht nachschauen. Und dann kannst du eben vor Gericht sagen, ich habe keine Ahnung, das sind alles Chaoten bei mir so, die hören auch nicht auf mich. Ähm,
Was meinen sie, was los ist, wenn ich mal einen Tag nicht da bin, dann tanzen die auf den Tischen und dann kommst du aus, kommst du aus der Nummer raus.
Wenn du aber sagst, äh wenn du aber sagst, hier Zeugnisverweigerung oder sonst was, ich haue meinen, ich haue keines meiner achtundzwanzig Kinder in die Pfanne, dann sagen die, ja, muss er aber. Äh du weißt es ja schließlich.
Unklug.
Hat gekostet ähm zweieinhalbtausend Euro plus Ersatz der Abmahnkosten von eintausenddreihundertachtzig Euro,
Das geht also nach wie vor ins Geld, da frage ich mich, was mit diesem Abmahndeckelungsgesetz äh was da jemals draus geworden ist. Also, wenn ihr irgendwann eine Abmahnung bekommt
nicht sagen, dass man weiß, wer es war. Es ist immer nicht feststellbar, wer es ist und man selber weiß nachweislich.
Genau. Praktische Lebenstipps von Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Man redet, man sagt sowieso nie, man weiß nie was. Wie viel Uhr es ist, nein, weiß ich nicht. Lassen sie mich, ich habe keine Ahnung.
So halten wir es auch hier im Podcast. Wir haben eigentlich keine Ahnung. Oder?
Weißt du, was ich heute beim vorbereiten der Sendung gedacht habe? Wir sind mal wieder nur Scheißnachrichten. Nur ausschließlich.
Ja auch von uns gewohnt. Wir werden das ändern. Wir werden uns irgendwas ausdenken. Wir machen einfach, wir denken uns einfach irgendwas aus, weil,
Zählt ja eh jetzt auch nichts mehr. Ne? Also professionelles Lügen ist ja mittlerweile total akzeptierter Sport. Wo man sich wahrscheinlich schon auf seine Visitenkarte drauf machen.
Professionell.
Lügenbold, ach wirklich, sie sind einer, sie sind einer von denen. Man hört ja so viel von ihnen.
Mangelt ja so schön. Sie sind diejenigen, die gegen Fake News kämpfen, nicht wahr?
Genau, zur Durchsetzung der wahren Ordnung und äh ja
Das ist alles äh da, da, da, da ziehe ich dann solchen Momenten, ziehe ich dann doch immer wieder die äh die Prinzipien des Kordiar hervor, da sind dann eigentlich irgendwie alle Antworten,
die man so braucht. Drin.
Oder? Also, wo du vorhin schon sagtest, so mit den Hackern, ne? So, man man hat so das Gefühl, alles was irgendwie damals äh so ein guter Witz war.
Das ist dann ähm heute alles so normal.
Äh wenn du mal im Militär oder was? Ja, ja, ja.
Ja, also alles, alles, was man so an an komischen Ideen hat und alles, was einem vollkommen absurd vorkam, das ist dann äh äh auf einmal irgendwie vollkommen normal,
und auch so diese dieses ganze alles dreht total durch und wenn man jetzt hier nur total übertreiben in der Beschreibung der Gesellschaft, da wird schon jedem irgendwie auffallen wie absurd das alles ist,
Ja. Zu kurz gedacht.
Ja, aber das ist auch das Krass ist auch das nutzt sicher ab. Du sitzt dann da irgendwie mit äh mit Ninetin Atie vor,
Und äh ne, also sie haben das in der Schule irgendwie damals behandelt, dann hat sie gesagt, ja, das wäre echt schlimm, wenn das so kommen würde, ne. Und dann sagst du irgendwann, dann sagst du ein Jahr lang, nein, ATY Forgus, noch zu poste, in den Struction Maniwe,
Und jetzt ist das irgendwie so könnte man das nennen. Äh Retro Science-Fiction, ne? Also irgendwie so historischer Roman,
Eigentlich historischer Roman äh in einer in einer anderen in einer anderen Steampunk-Welt, aber das haben wir eigentlich schon längst.
Ja, vom Science-Fiction zum Schulheft und.
So hat man sich das, so hat man sich das damals vorgestellt, lustig, ne? Die haben fliegende Autos. Aber sonst haben die das eigentlich ganz gut äh erfasst. So, ne? Apple oder die tanzen mit Rücken, an den Rücken, aber sonst haben die eigentlich alles ganz gut hingekriegt,
Schlimm ist es. Aber weil ich hier in diesem Gespräch über die ähm
Über die ethischen Prinzipien der Hacker oder sowas oder das oder man ist jetzt irgendwie überrascht oder so, weil,
Darf ich äh mit der mit dem besagten Journalisten auch über die Tuwa TXT gesprochen.
Ähm und da war ich äh die habe hatte ich angebracht, die ist erschienen, am ersten September neunzehnhunderteinundachtzig. Das ist ja echt lange her, ne? Ähm ein, ich glaube eine Woche später gilt dann, als der Gründungstag des Chaos-Computerclub.
Ja, zwölfter September dann.
So öfter, ne? Ähm und darf,
muss man auch sagen, so zu überlegen, seit wie vielen Jahren äh schon sagen, dass die innere Sicherheit erst durch Computereinsatz möglich wird, glauben die mächtigen heute alle. Das ist neunzehnhunderteinundachtzig geschrieben, ne?
Also man muss vielleicht nochmal kurz sagen, was es ist. Also Tuwa TXT ist äh im Prinzip eine eine äh Annance von Frau Holland in der Tarz.
Und Tom Twittelbit.
Und Tom Twitterbit die äh aufgerufen hat zu einem Treffen, was dann auch äh stattfand, in der Tat und äh,
aus diesem Treffen heraus kam äh wow mit der Motivation äh doch jetzt mal was zu tun und äh ganz konkret einen Club zu gründen und das war dann eben der Chaos-Computerclub. Von daher ist das so ein so ein bisschen so dieses äh äh Dokument.
TXT tatsächlich noch ein alter äh äh Form S Tradition.
Ähm.
Und jetzt kommt der Text.
Möchtest du ihn vorlesen? Ich sehe, dass ich das äh möchtest du machen.
Ja, ich habe da auch schon mal eine eine Chaos-Radio-Express zu gemacht, ne.
Weiß ich. Müssen wir auch verlinken.
Dass die dass die innere Sicherheit erst durch Computereinsatz möglich wird, glauben die Mächtigen heute alle,
dass Computer nicht streiken, setzt sich als Erkenntnis langsam auch bei mittleren Unternehmen durch,
das durch Computereinsatz das Telefon noch schöner wird, glaubt die Post heute mit ihrem Bildschirmtextsystem in Feldversuchen beweisen zu müssen,
dass der Personalcomputer nun in Deutschland im Video gesättigten BMW-Fahrer angedreht werden soll, wird durch die nun einsetzenden Anzeigenkampagnen klar,
das sich mit kleinen Computern trotz alledem sinnvolle Sachen machen lassen, die keine äh,
vielleicht der Tricks äh zentralisierten, Zentrierten, was steht da.
Großorganisationen fordern glauben wir, damit wir als Computerfreaks FRIKS nicht länger unkoordiniert von Zinnwuseln tun wir was und treffen uns et cetera Datum und so weiter,
Wir reden über internationale Netzwerke, Kommunikationsrecht,
Datenrecht in Klammern wem gehören meine Daten? Copyright, Informations und Lernsysteme, Datenbanken, Encription, Computerspiele, Puramiersprachen, Process Control, Hardware und was auch immer.
Das ist wirklich ab, das ist so krass, also einundachtzig. Und ganz ehrlich, ich äh.
Bin da ja schon irgendwie wach rumgelaufen äh in dieser Zeit und ich kann euch sagen,
Computer waren damals einfach für niemanden auf der Agenda. Also das war einfach äh nicht nur so,
dass Leute sich dafür nicht interessiert haben, es war einfach nicht da, also es es gab keine ähm niemand hatte einen.
Kein kein Handy.
Dass.
Die Rande ohne Handy im Wald rum.
Der Herr, das war ja nochmal zehn Jahre später.
Ja. Aber.
Also auch also keiner hatte auch eine konkrete Vorstellung davon, was das ist. Computer, das war
große Geräte, die man in Spielfilmen sah und wenn man halt bei IBM gearbeitet hat oder mit einem großen Unternehmen, dann gab's so einen Raum, wo dann die Herren äh mit ihren Schlipsen und so weiter rumhingen. Das waren so Computer. Man wusste, es gab welche, aber,
Dass das in irgendeiner Form mit einem,
selbst was zu tun haben könnte, dass dieses Gerät in irgendeiner Form Teil des eigenen Lebens wird und dieses Leben dann auch irgendwann mal bestimmt et cetera. Das das das gab's nicht, ja? Und das das die Runde schon in der Ankündigung,
Das finde ich ist halt auch eins der Vermächtnisse, die ich klar wow äh zuschreibe, der einfach immer die Dinge der Zeit gut erfasst hat,
es äh haut mich auch immer noch wieder um. Nur es liest sich ja im Prinzip wie wie was so in der Tagesschau alles so über die Woche.
Mehr als dass es mehr als fünfunddreißig Jahre her, ne? Dieser Text ist älter als ich und nimmt alle Probleme, die wir heute diskutieren, nimmt der in wenigen Zeilen kurz mal eben auf, unser.
Müssen wir mal drüber reden.
Wahnsinn. Also je, ich bin jedes Mal äh begeistert, wenn ich den Richter sehe. Nein.
So, ich hoffe, ihr bald jetzt auch begeistert. Äh wir verabschieden uns und sagen tschüs.
Ciao ciao.